[Musique]
après six semaines de guerre l'exode de
nombreux arméniens installés dans la
région du haut-karabakh scènes de
désolation avec une politique de terre
brûlée systématique avant l'arrivée des
azéris les soldats russes sont en cours
de déploiement dans cette enclave
une mission de maintien de la paix qui
va durer au moins cinq ans le plus grand
pacte commercial au monde signé
aujourd'hui entre la chine lazer années
les pays du pacifique cet accord vise à
créer une gigantesque zone de libre
échange il va conserver plus de deux
milliards d'habitants
un pacte qui consolide également les
ambitions géopolitiques régional de la
chine
autour des nouvelles routes de la soie
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce dimanche la colère des
catholiques de france qui ne peuvent
plus assister à la messe à l'église à
cause du confinement plus d'une
centaines de croyants rassemblez vous
voyez à versailles ou encore à bois
colombes dans les hauts-de-seine
à paris la préfecture de police a
interdit le rassemblement prévu devant
l'église saint sulpice dans le 6e
arrondissement c'était là où plusieurs
dizaines de fidèles avaient prié
vendredi soir pour réclamer le retour de
la messe un culte qu'ils considèrent
comme essentiels écoutez le gouvernement
veut en fait agi comme s'ils allaient à
la messe était allé acheter un produit
non essentiels selon eux et c'est alors
que ces critiques pour toutes les
personnes qui sont ici on pourrait très
bien organiser des messes avec un nombre
de personnes réduit avec des conditions
strictes et ils veulent même pas
entendre ça et cette réclamation de de
la messe
pour moi c'est important que nous ne
comprenons pas cette décision de la part
du gouvernement nous sommes là pour
exiger comme dans tous les autres
rassemblements de france dans toutes les
autres manifestations
le retour de la messe en présence des
fidèles à une mobilisation des
catholiques également à bordeaux ce
matin bordeaux où un des organisateurs
de la manifestation a fait savoir je
cite que la police avait noté des gestes
contraire à la laïcité dans l'espace
public et qu'il était donc convoqué au
commissariat lundi matin demain les
responsables du culte catholique seront
reçus par l'exécutif le gouvernement
doit entendre leur colère avertit jean
frédéric poisson président du parti la
voix du peuple
nous devons absolument faire comprendre
ce gouvernement que la façon dont il
gère cette crise est insupportable
qu'elle ne ressemble à rien qu'elle n'a
aucun sens et on voit bien que l'on va
de contradictions en contradictions et
ne n'accepteront pas de payer de nos
libertés le prix de cette incohérence
ici la raison pour laquelle tu alerté
déjà il ya quelques jours sur le fait
que
il ne faudrait pas que le gouvernement
ait l'intention nous empêcher de nous
réunir pour noël parce que là la rage
que je sens poindre et qui s'expriment
parfois dans le peuple français pourrait
prendre je pense des proportions
incontrôlables on peut faire très très
attention à ça quand on veut en bray
quand on veut tenir les défoncer bride
courte comme disent les prémices ne
sonne pas des chevaux
nous sommes des personnes humaines
besoin de vie culturelle et sociale
le ministre de l'intérieur qui réunira
donc demain matin pour la seconde fois
les représentants des principaux cultes
gérald darmanin qui veut aussi revoir la
répartition de la police et de la
gendarmerie sur le territoire à l'heure
actuelle la gendarmerie opère plutôt en
zone rurale et la police dans les villes
dans une interview dans la presse hier
le ministre de l'intérieur a annoncé une
réorganisation à partir de l'année
prochaine avec une plus grande
coopération
écoutez il est hors de question de
toucher à notre modèle qui voit agir
deux forces complémentaires mais il ya
une mauvaise répartition entre police et
gendarmerie sur le plan national il faut
sans tabou aller vers une organisation
plus efficace
j'ouvre ce chantier qui n'avait pas été
ouvert depuis des dizaines d'années et
alors que les premiers effets durent
confinement commence à se faire sentir
en france des universitaires appellent
le gouvernement à réfléchir dès
maintenant aux déconfinement notamment
en organisant une campagne de dépistage
massif
ils appellent de leurs voeux je cite un
déconfinement durable solidaire et
citoyen pour noël et un avenir serein
regardez il faut d'abord réduire
drastiquement le nombre des porteurs du
virus
en identifiant toutes les personnes
asymptomatiques dans la population
française
ces dernières sans le savoir
maintiennent le virus en circulation en
particulier dans notre sphère privée ou
légitimement nous avons tendance à
baisser la garde
cette identification peut être réalisé
grâce à une campagne de dépistage massif
nationale sur un temps très court
c'est un enjeu certes complexe mais à
notre portée nous sommes bien capable de
faire voter 52 millions de français en
un week-end aussi pour nous nous
inspirer de cette logistique bien rodée
pour organiser ce dépistage pour qu'il
soit pleinement efficace
nous devons prévoir dès à présent des
tests antigénique en quantité suffisante
et organiser les conditions d'un
isolement effectifs des personnes
positives avec l'aide de structures
hôtelières et voyez ce qu'en dit
françois blanchecotte il est responsable
des laboratoires d'analysés médicales
avaient ou plus en indre et loire
également président national du syndicat
des biologistes
on est tenté comme d'autres pays
européens la slovaquie l'a fait mais il
n'avait que 5,4 millions d'habitants 65
millions d'habitants c'est c'est
redoutable parce qu'il faut sur des
tests rapides même s'ils sont
techniquement rapide c'est quand même
des tests que nous faisons un par un
donc c'est extrêmement compliqué de le
faire ça me paraît un défi extrêmement
redoutable et je suis pas sûr que l'on
soit en capacité aujourd'hui de
l'organiser je pense qu'il ya plusieurs
pistes de réflexion qu'il faut mettre
ensemble il faut certainement voir la
plus efficiente et la plus réalisable de
façon à ce qu'on sache exactement et
qu'on ne fasse pas les erreurs du 11 mai
landes et confinant et en laissant
évidemment le virus circule et et colère
des commerçants également en france des
restaurateurs et des cafetiers il
prépare un recours contre la fermeture
de leur établissement
ils justifient leur démarche par la
rupture du principe d'égalité selon un
des professionnels qui demandent à
rouvrir à l'approché des fêtes de noël
on voit cela en images regarder
[Musique]
nous
[Rires]
[Musique]
oh
[Rires]
[Musique]
la fermeture administrative de nos
restaurants et bars s'appuie sur des
raisons sanitaires
or aucune donnée chiffrée ne permet de
justifier que les cas de contamination
ont été plus nombreux dans ces
établissements de type n que dans la
restauration collective
les restaurateurs traditionnels et les
bars applique depuis leurs premières
réouvertures en juin 2020 les mêmes
protocoles sanitaires strictes
appliquées par la restauration
collective et ce dans le but d'assurer
la sécurité sanitaire des salariés et
des clients
[Rires]
des professionnels dans une situation
très difficile actuellement c'est ce que
nous explique franck delvaux il est
coprésident de l'union des métiers et
des industries de l'hôtellerie à paris
ile de france
le stop and go qui est très dur à gérer
je vous rappelle que depuis le mois de
mars on a été confiné ensuite en ers
ouvert uniquement les terrasses ensuite
on a pu rouvrir nos salles ensuite on a
eu le couvre-feu maintenant de nouveau
le confinement et aucune perspective
on ne sait pas le gouvernement ne nous a
toujours pas dit quand est ce qu'on va
réouvrir ce sera quand ce sera 18
décembre ce sera au mois de janvier au
mois de février
le protocole sanitaire a déjà été
renforcée puisque on a limité les tables
à 6 couverts par table ans maximum
l'encaissement doit se faire à table et
on avait mis en place le cahier de
rappel on voyait on est allé déjà très
loin dans le protocole sanitaire
donc maintenant on le renforcer et non
si on le renforce encore alors mieux
vaut rester fermés puisque en plus ou
étant donné la météo on ne peut plus
avoir accès à notre terrasse donc
aujourd'hui il est déjà très renforcée à
95%
les professionnels le suivent c'est à
l'état de fermer les 5 % qu'ils veulent
pas respecter protocole sanitaire des
restrictions sanitaires de moins en
moins bien acceptée en france mais aussi
en europe où plusieurs manifestations se
sont encore déroulé ce week-end françois
fiscalité
le canon à eau employés dans les rues de
francfort pour disperser une centaine de
manifestants anti racistes venus
protester contre la manifestation
organisée dans le centre ville à l'appel
du collectif queer wenger plusieurs
centaines de personnes ont répondu à
l'appel de ce mouvement pour dénoncer
les restrictions en particulier le port
du masque et la fermeture des bars et
restaurants le collectif couarde en
choeur les anticonformistes ou libres
penseurs en français étaient déjà
l'initiative de plusieurs rassemblements
ces derniers mois dont celui du 7
novembre dernier à l'aps ich où des
violences avaient éclaté lors d'une
manifestation réunissant près de vingt
mille personnes en angleterre
la police leur avait demandé d'annuler
leurs manifestations
mais les organisateurs ont maintenu leur
appel pour protester contre le
confinement en place dans le pays
jusqu'au 2 décembre prochain à bristol
ou à liverpool
des dizaines de manifestants ont été
arrêtés par la police
manifestation plus calme à lisbonne au
portugal où plusieurs centaines de
personnes ont bravé le couvre-feu entré
en vigueur ce samedi les week-ends de 13
heures à 5 heures du matin les portugais
ont désormais l'interdiction de sortir
de chez eux
une interdiction de circuler des gens
vigueur la semaine entre 23h et 5h on
s'en sort pas les gens n'ont plus
d'argent cette mesure de couvre feu il
fallait la faire en mars ou en avril
cela ne peut pas être maintenant pas
maintenant des manifestations qui
devraient se poursuivre un peu partout
en europe dans les prochains jours voire
les prochains mois alors que plusieurs
dirigeants européens annonce qu'il va
falloir vivre avec le virus sur le long
terme jusqu'à l'arrivée d'un vaccin
après six semaines de guerre l'exode de
nombreux arméniens installés dans la
région du haut karabakh à l'azerbaïdjan
leur a donné encore dix jours pour
évacuer la zone ainsi qu'aux militaires
sur place
scène de désolation avec une politique
de terre brûlée systématique avant
l'arrivée des azéri les soldats russes
sont en cours de déploiement dans cette
enclave une mission de maintien de la
paix qui va durer au moins cinq ans
aujourd'hui l'arménie pleure ses morts
au moins de 1300 soldats ont été tués et
on va en parler tout de suite avec notre
correspondant sur place kirill kotick
off qui se trouve actuellement à la
frontière entre l'arménie et le haut
karabagh
bonsoir kirill vous êtes donc à cette
frontière avec le haut-karabakh comment
évolue la situation sur place ce soir
bonsoir mag allié alors nous nous
trouvons dans la ville de gori ville de
25000 habitants comme vous l'avez dit
avec à la frontière du haut karabagh à
deux heures de route environ de
stepanakert où nous devrions être
acheminés d'ici peu alors il y a deux
choses essentielles à retenir de
l'évolution actuelle de la situation la
première c'est qu'un avion du ministère
russe des situations d'urgence avec à
son bord une trentaine de spécialistes
et du matériel médical et militaire a
atterri il ya quelques heures à
l'aéroport de yerevan le contingent
devrait être acheminée dans le
haut-karabagh pour apporter son aide aux
populations qui sont en train de revenir
dans leurs maisons et moscou a fait
savoir qu'il pourrait envoyer une aide
supplémentaire de 150 spécialistes ainsi
que potentiellement un hôpital
aéroportée si la situation l'exigeait la
deuxième c'est que l'azerbaïdjan a donné
un l'arménie un report pour le retrait
de ses troupes de la ville de khar
vachard en arménien qui est devenu
kelbadjar en azéri et ce jusqu'au 25
décembre selon bakou c'est par cette
route qui s'étend entre kelbadjar et
goris nous nous trouvons que tout ça
chemine transport de matériel de blessés
arrivés et départs
tout passe par cette route qui est un
point essentiel et stratégique et c'est
dans cette ville de kehl badge art qu'il
y a quelques jours nous pouvions voir
des arméniens préféré brûlé leurs
maisons
plutôt que de les abandonner aux
azerbaïdjanais voilà donc pour ces deux
points importants et je rappelle par
ailleurs que les équipes du centre
interministériel de réaction humanitaire
basée à stepanakert et sous l'égide de
moscou poursuit son travail depuis le 14
novembre environ 725 personnes ont pu
être escorté par bus via le couloir de
latchine dans le haut-karabagh sur place
que la logistique progresse en tout cas
oui effectivement la logistique
progresse il n'y a pas que la dimension
logistique il ya aussi la logistique le
problème humain comment est-ce que ces
deux peuples vont pouvoir s'entendre
alors qu on assiste véritablement à une
passation de territoire le président
aliyev le président azéri a assuré à
vladimir poutine que les lieux de culte
arménien par exemple serait préservée
sauvegarde est placée sous protection et
que les arméniens vivant dans le
haut-karabagh pourrait continuer à s'y
rendre en toute liberté
dans les faits la situation pour être
pourrait être un peu plus compliqué on
sait que durant ces six semaines de
conflit certains lieux de culte
arméniens ont été fortement endommagées
par l'armée azérie et nos équipes ont pu
recueillir le témoignage d'un prêtre
orthodoxe il est recteur dans le village
de da divan qu il est attristé de devoir
rétrocéder ses terres à l'azerbaïdjan et
il craint évidemment pour les lieux de
culte écoutez je ne crois pas encore que
nous devions donner des divans cause
azerbaïdjanaise
mysoft aujourd'hui je vois que nous
devons donner ses terres à une nation
qui n'a pas la conscience de la valeur
et de la sainteté de ces terres assez
territoire gbp je ressens une énorme
douleur dit ton est un conflit qui dure
depuis plus de 30 ans la situation qui
n'a jamais été résolue qu'on est il de
la partie azérie qui rime ce soir
écouter dans une guerre comme ça rien
n'est jamais tout blanc ou tout noir les
deux parties ont leur propre vérité
auquel elle croit dur comme fer
évidemment côté azerbaïdjanais les
réfugiés d'hyères sont heureux de
pouvoir retrouver les terres qu'ils
avaient dû fuir et nos équipes basées à
bas coût ont pu recueillir quelques
témoignages de manifestants sur place
écoutez nous avons été contraints de
quitter feeds au lit en octobre 1993 via
l'iran depuis nous nous sommes installés
ici dans le dortoir de l'université
polytechnique grâce à
l'aide du président nous y retournerons
il nous le permettront nous y
retournerons en bas nous n'avons plus
d'endroit où vivre affi giuly toutes les
maisons sont détruites
moscou et erevan et bakou semble en tout
cas s'être véritablement mis d'accord
sur l'application de ce cessez le feu
les ministres des affaires étrangères
des trois pays ont souligné dans un
dialogue commun je cite l'importance
d'établir une coopération avec le haut
commissariat des nations unies pour les
réfugiés
l'unesco le comité international de la
croix rouge ainsi que d'autres
organisations multilatérales afin
d'alléger la situation des civils dans
la zone de conflit et de préserver les
sites religieux et culturels merci
beaucoup kiri pour toutes ces précisions
qui rit la côte eekhof depuis la
frontière entre l'arménie et le haut
karabagh et pour en parler on nous
sommes en direct ce soir avec françoise
souvent si les général de brigade et
expert en géopolitique
bonsoir françois chossy merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur ft france on va
essayer de faire simple sur cette
situation de de cessez le feu en dans le
haut karabakh il y à l'enclavé du
haut-karabakh et des zones autour du
lait les arméniens sont en train de
quitter justement cette zone pour
regagner l arménie et il y à la
situation dans le haut karabakh ou là il
ya encore des arméniens comment ces
armes ignobles ont-ils pouvoir être
protégé est ce que ça va être une des
parties de la mission russe sans aucun
doute je crois que dès qu'il ya une
sortie de crise avec une population
civile qui pourraient échanger qui a
peur d'ailleurs des représailles
éventuelles finalement de la populaire
de l'armée azérie il est tout à fait
normal qu'une force 10 d'apport ta
position puisse se mettre en contact en
interposition entre ces forces armées et
là puis las aussi
donc c'est tout à fait normal ça se fait
partout pour justement assurer une
sortie de crise
acceptable et quelles vont être les
autres missions de ces soldats russes
assurer des liaisons entre l'arménie et
cette enclave du haut karabagh oui sans
aucun doute puisqu'il ya un sens de
coordination qui est prévu justement
avec l'état-major russe je dirais sur
place bon c'est 2000 hommes comme ton
déployé ce n'est pas rien ensuite on
sait que les troupes russes sont quand
même des troupes qui sont efficaces et
tout sera fait sans aucun doute pour
qu'il n'y ait aucune dérive locale et
que la transition entre je dirais le
nouveau régime azéri se passe bien pour
éviter que justement il y ait des
solutions violentes localement ont donc
c'est c'est ce qui va se passer
certainement d'un point de vue
géopolitique en quoi les azéri avait à
gagner à signer cet accord puisque ils
ont maintenant des troupes russes sur
leur sol je me demande si les azéris
s'attendait à voir des troupes ce russe
en interposition mais je pense que le
président poutine a su faire preuve je
dirais d'autorité au bout de six
semaines où je pense pas qu'il en ait
fait beaucoup du moins il n'a pas
exprimé une position très forte et a
laissé les combats se déroulent et je
dirais que c'est un petit peu le retour
sur investissement à terme ou oui les
troupes les arbitres jean doit accepter
des troupes russes
c'est peut-être la seule condition pour
que le cessez le feu se maintiennent et
puis un autre côté je pense aussi que
c'est un moyen pour la russie de
préserver l'arménie qui sort quand même
bien amoindrie de cette situation
militaire et est-ce qu'on peut pas dire
ce soir qu'il y amener en moins même si
le statu quo officiellement n'existe
plus mais cette enclave du haut karabagh
est toujours à majorité arménienne
même si elle est officiellement j'ai
réparé par les azerbaïdjanais
aujourd'hui alors c'est en club quand on
regarde bien c'est cent cinquante mille
personnes 150 mille arméniens dont
depuis quinze jours ont dit qu'elles
quittent la zone
je ne crois pas comme ça c'est vu
ailleurs d'ailleurs que les arméniens
voudront rester sous l'autorité de
l'azerbaïdjan
donc je pense que nous allons assister à
des déplacements de population ah si
nous mêmes un exode et que là il faudra
bien que l'arménie prennent en compte
ces nouveaux exilés sur un territoire
quand même qui est pas très grand avec
des moyens limités et sans doute que la
russie n'hésitera pas à aider à la
réinstallation de cette population
arménienne qui est obligé de quitter une
zone dans lesquelles s'est installée si
l'arménie n'avait pas signé cet accord
de cessez-le-feu est ce qu'elle aurait
encore plus perdus aujourd'hui on sait
que le premier ministre est très
critiquée oui bah il ya la question de
politique intérieure quand un politicien
pire une guerre ça se paye vis à vis aux
opinions publiques surtout quand il ya
des élections
bon bah je pense que c'est un peu dans
tous les pays ce serait un peu comme
cela
d'un autre côté l'arménie aurait pu
perdre beaucoup plus je pense
mais si l'azerbaïdjan a étalé était allé
plus loin que les enclaves
je pense que la russie aurait été
contrainte d'intervenir au nom de la
protection de l'arménie je vous rappelle
que l'arménie fait partie de la même
alliance militaire et de sécurité que la
russie est qu'à ces titres-là la russie
se devrait et aurait dû le protéger
ce qui ne concerne pas le karabakh le
haut-karabakh ce n'était pas dans
l'accord n'était pas dans l'alliance
maintenant si laser ridge en est allé
plus loin
oui je pense que la russie aurait été
largement duilhé et donc le cessez le
feu était obligatoire quelles
conséquences pour le paysage régional la
russie renforce son influence régionale
qu'en est il de la turquie qui est assez
absente de cet accord de cessez-le-feu
je pense que tout a été fait pour que la
turquie ne soit pas présente
parce que la turquie a une tendance
aujourd'hui à avoir une volonté
expansionniste
il est certain que l'aide qu'elle a
apportée à des arbitres jean a permis la
victoire de l'azerbaïdjan mais pas
uniquement un je vous rappelle que 65%
de l'équipement
azéri est d'origine russe et pâtures
qu'un malgré des drones envoyés par les
turcs malgré des supplétifs islamistes
envoyés donc effectivement la turquie
mises de côté mais pourquoi parce que la
turquie a une volonté islamiste très bon
c'est quand on envoie des supplétifs
islamistes venant de syrie je comprends
aussi que la russie soit peut-être un
peu inquiète tu n'as pas envie du tout à
mon avis d'avoir ce genre de deux
miliciens ses frontières je pense qu'il
doit y avoir aussi des pressions sur la
turquie pour qu'elle reste mesuré dans
ses peut-être éventuelle revendication
par exemple au à la sortie politique de
la crise ou un film en elle et pas du
tout présente elle est allée deux côtés
voilà merci beaucoup françois choix ans
et d'avoir répondu ce soir en direct à
nos questions sur rt france c'est le
plus grand impact commercial au monde et
il a été signé aujourd'hui entre la
chine l'asian et des pays du pacifique
il va créer une gigantesque zone de
libre échange de plus de deux milliards
d'habitants
un pacte qui consolide au passage les
ambitions géopolitiques régional de la
chine autour des nouvelles routes de la
soie grâce d'ailleurs l'accord
commercial le plus important du monde
c'est ce que reflètent l'accord conclu
ce dimanche selon de nombreux analystes
porté majoritairement par la chine
il inclut également le japon la corée du
sud l'australie et la nouvelle-zélande
en tout quinze pays sont concernés les
économies mondiales et régionales sont
confrontés à d'immenses obstacles et
défis découlant non seulement du convive
19 mais aussi de la diminution du
commerce mondial la conclusion des
négociations du rcp partenariat
économique régionale globale le plus
grand accord de libre échange au monde
enverra un message fort qui affirme le
rôle de premier plan de l'asian dans le
soutien du système commercial
multilatéral
la création d'une nouvelle structure
commerciale dans la région
la facilitation du commerce durable la
revitalisation des chaînes
d'approvisionnement perturbé par le cos
vite 19 et l'aide à la reprise post
pandémie un partenariat qui vise à créer
une gigantesque zone de libre-échange
entre les dix états de laser
et cinq autres est un majeur de la zone
pacifique un accord fondamental
puisqu'il concerne 2 milliard
d'habitants et 30 % du pib mondial
il consolide les ambitions géopolitiques
des nouvelles routes de la soie outil
majeur de la chine dans sa stratégie d'
influence dans les circonstances
mondiale actuelle le fait que le rc ep
était signé après huit ans de
négociations apporte un rayon de lumière
et d'espoir au milieu des nuages
ce partenariat vient remplacer
naturellement la place laissée vide par
le traité de libre échange
transpacifique porté par obama et dont
donald trump avait retiré les états unis
peu après son entrée en fonction absent
également l'inde qui avait abandonné
l'accord l'an dernier de peur de voir
des produits chinois à bas coûts envahir
son marché de son côté l'organisation
des nations unies appelle les états
concernés à prendre en compte les
nouveaux défis du monde actuel
la communauté internationale est
confrontée à une tempête parfaite une
pandémie mondiale l'urgence climatique
des tensions géopolitiques croissantes
le risque de prolifération nucléaire
une pauvreté persistante et des
inégalités croissantes au conflit bien
ancrée et l'apparition de nouveaux
conflits
le monde n'est pas sur la bonne voie
pour atteindre les objectifs de
développement durable d'ici 2030
je compte sur votre leadership et votre
détermination à prendre des mesures
urgentes pour sauvegarder notre monde
comment barack obama avait initié en son
temps un pivot vers l'asie que la
présidence trump et son america first
ont mis entre parenthèses une nouvelle
administration démocrate pourrait
marquer le retour des etats-unis dans la
zone pacifique et voyez l'analyse à
présent d'un jouet l'aurait-il et
économiste au cnrs et président de the
bridge bank
le commerce bilatéral entre la chine et
l'asie inde c'est à peu près 650
milliards de dollars en tout cas si on
projette sur l'année 2020 ce qui s'est
passé sur les trois premier trimestres
si on prend alors évidemment c'est pas
simplement au niveau de la chine l'asian
si on prend par exemple le commerce
bilatéral entre le japon et la zea nez
est à peu près 150 milliards entre le
japon et la chine qui sont dans des
cosignataires du net de 100 milliards
etc
il faudrait regarder lens en mai
on culmine à 1000 milliards ou à peu
près rien que le commerce intra union
européenne sans compter sans compter le
royaume uni évidemment on est à 3000
milliards soit 3 fois plus voyez donc en
termes d'intégration des économies
moi je dirais c'est à la fois un pas
majeur parce que ça faisait huit ans qui
avait cette négociation mais ça n'est
qu'un premier pas donc c'est peut-être
une très grande zone économique mais
c'est une zone qui n'est pas si intégré
que ça qui est en voie d'intégration et
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité on se retrouve dans 30
minutes
restez rigaux
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut être défenseurs du
climat de la nature et des animaux et en
même temps aimait la chasse bien sûr
c'est avoir conscience justement des
populations de comment les gérer si
aujourd'hui on arrive à plus ou moins
trouver un équilibre entre la
l'urbanisation l'agriculture
et puis les espaces naturels c'est grâce
à la chasse grâce aux chasseurs
selon des ong la chasse et la cause de
disparition de certaines espèces j'ai
bien l'impression que les espèces sont
sont en grande partie conservée grâce à
la gestion des chasseurs aujourd'hui
vous avez